[Music]
before you see Halloween the sequel to
the original Halloween but not Halloween
- and definitely not this other movie
called Halloween - okay wait let me
start over before you see the third
Halloween - that's right in it
be sure to revisit Halloween the first
one not the new one and not the other
movie called Halloween boy this
franchise is a mess it's Halloween night
in a small town and everyone is horny
like super horny okay first I rip your
clothes off then you rip my clothes off
then we rip Lindsay's clothes off yeah I
think I know you're joking but Lindsay's
a child you creep but this year a killer
is on the loose and he's inventing or
cementing every slasher cliche will get
for the next 40 years like wearing a
creepy mask making spooky phone calls
only targeting suburban teenagers only
letting the final virgin girl survive
and eating dogs so was that Mars the
only one who actually eats a dog's
probably for the best before Jamie Lee
Curtis was a scream queen her mom was in
psycho making her a mere screen princess
watch her goody two-shoes Lauri
try to survive the night with her friend
Annie and a whole and Linda starved the
drinking game take a shot every time
Linda says totally so may the best
Halloween ever you guys you're totally
the window the best I love yous how to
kill this baby-sitters club is Michael
Myers one of cinema's most iconic
mouth-breathers
[Applause]
forget Instagram cuz he stalking girls
the old-fashioned way standing in clear
view of them then somehow batmanning
into thin air when they're briefly
distracted
[Applause]
[Music]
but Michael is just a monster made by
the film's real Frankenstein Loomis a
psychiatrist with a very loose grasp of
psychiatry I spent eight years trying to
reach him and then another seven trying
to keep him locked up who doesn't
exactly follow the Hippocratic oath
really messed up this kid's face at some
point and doesn't even obey handicapped
parking signs create an unstoppable
killing machine okay fine but you were
parked outside a medical facility sir
where is your placard dick so strapped
in with one of the greatest horror films
of all time from carpenters masterfully
tense directing and original score to
Deborah Hills racer focused writing and
production to Jamie Lee Curtis and star
turn against a brand-new horror icon
just be sure to follow the upcoming
sequels lead and pretend none of the
other movies ever happened trust us
[Music]
starring the shape of slaughter Laurie
Strode up to the wrong house
that's for sure I'm talking about ya
jokes are fun dr. evil Casey Affleck the
old man who knows the town's dark secret
watch I'm boned he got himself a hacksaw
and he kissed his wife and his two
children goodbye and then he preceded
the horny friend the somewhat less horny
but still kind of horny friend and the
mystery creeper in the backseat of this
car
while Michael drives like a lookout
there's someone else in the back of the
car it's probably Loomis adventures in
babysitting
you know what the real horror is living
in a home or your parents only buy you
the Kirkland select knockoff comic books
laser man Neutron man I can understand
why tarantula man worst cinematic
universe ever effervescent apple fritter
riboflavin oh dang Josh I want my
avocado pancreas I got the meat sweats
llanfair pour quit you know what ah
that's bait